right you might get a nipple shot but
you can censor that we're conjuring my
boobs oh my god this is like my greatest
dream I didn't hell it was a thing I
have too much being really excited get
that very small booth I used to never be
subconscious up my boobs until it was
using like an insult I think it's a lot
I hope I don't like this already this is
more makeup than I've ever owned it
looks like I'm supposed to take a really
dark color and draw a big line
this is erotic right now it looks like
chest hair yeah or like a skidmark oh
you do a curve is so funny it looks like
I'm drawing a dick on my chest look it's
just like nobody can touch you if you've
done this give someone a hug and they're
like oh sorry those are my breasts
see ya this is like what kind of imagine
girls do at sleepovers real titillated
right okay so now I blend it now this is
where it all of a sudden turns into Kim
Kardashian woo
okay looks worse than before I kind of
see it a little bit this way you want
world Pacheco's insane
they're definitely lopsided like this
one's killing it right now I painted my
chest tan
[Music]
are you impressed with what I did
um impressed as a word read I'm using a
burgundy burgundy so I picked the wrong
color the chest believing look so
special effects for your boobs this
makes me feel like I wouldn't be in the
Lion King actually I'm not kidding you
did beautiful see look at where now
we're getting that like khlifa yeah
check it out ooh now it kind of looks
like that painting like the screen
welcome to the makeup video everything's
fake and everyone's alive this takes too
long for me to ever do this on my own so
did you say this is like an everyday not
fair okay this looks very natural I
can't what do you think what I'm like
Barbie holy [ __ ] I don't like it this is
everything they ever wanted oh man I've
got mega bunches the girls are out today
now I'm unstoppable
I'm impressed it looks so natural and so
decent however isn't that what I look
like certainly read this fake to me I
don't know if I'd ever realistically do
this but yeah they look amazing I had
over expectation I mean it's just
accentuating what's already there this
makes me feel like I have won a mass you
know that they feel like if I didn't
have contoured boobs you probably might
be able to touch my boob later on the
date if you like played your cards right
I am trying to get to a place where I
accept my body for what it is and doing
this seems like the exact opposite of
that if this is the kind of thing that
you don't feel like would inhibit you
bracket I think it also showed me that
like I have perfect amount to work with
as it is the end of the day you should
be giving it for yourself you know I
made sure to do before I came here was
like do a quick scan of the breast area
and pluck those like random hairs that
you get you guys please say people gnome
talks I know people totally know
[Music]